i'm going to tell you something
something others have only guessed at
do wizards go to the dentist or not
today we're looking at some of the most
confusing details of life in the
wizarding world what students do before
and after hogwarts isn't so clear there
are also a shocking amount of gaps in
knowledge of muggle life
said it was hogwarts business very
secret
we have seen a lot in the wizarding
world broken bones literally being fixed
by magic people apparating from anywhere
so why isn't there any magic spell that
exists that can help fix his eyesight
that's better isn't it
gillyweed gave harry literal gills so he
could breathe underwater yet there's no
spell plant or magical object that can
improve harry's eyesight
your eyesight really is awful wizards
for whatever reason are often quite
clueless about what happens in the
muggle world what exactly is the
function of a rubber duck
oh but where does the magic world stand
on dentistry when hermione mentions her
parents or dentists in the muggle world
they tend to people's teeth fascinating
and is that considered a dangerous
profession slughorn and his slug club
seem very confused by the idea alright
so witches and wizards don't need
dentists except in the weasley's house
there is the clock with all the family
members faces on it with places that
they could be listed one place these
witches and wizards could potentially be
is you guessed it the dentist although
one boy robbie fenwick did bite my
father once
in the first film the new hogwarts
students are surprised by the sorting
hat which doesn't make that much sense
since it's been such a long-standing
tradition why are so many unaware of
this major moment there are loads of
families who've attended hogwarts surely
a parent or sibling could mention the
major moment to future hogwarts students
you can choose gryffindor
the sorting hat takes your choice into
account
ready
the third floor corridor at hogwarts may
have been locked but anyone using the
alahomora charm could access it easily
one would think they would put a bit
more effort into the security system
tell them hogwarts
is no longer safe
students who go to hogwarts have to head
to platform nine and three quarters in
central london to hop on the train to
scotland for the students from scotland
going to the trouble of traveling to
london just to catch the train back
seems pretty nonsensical
do you have any idea how serious this is
part of the tragedy of voldemort taking
james and lily potter's lives is that
the two of them were so young just 21.
however every time we see them they look
more like they are in their 30s or 40s
we never left
you'll stay with me
until the end
hogwarts is consistently called an
extremely safe place but as we've
learned over the course of the movies
hogwarts is a very hazardous place for
young people to be living and learning
in half the time the professors are the
ones causing the danger to students
why is it always me
punishment involving sending someone to
the forbidden forest alone is definitely
not something we can imagine any school
getting away with how a student didn't
fall off or somehow get injured on the
wild stairs is beyond us the students
also interact with incredibly powerful
creatures including hippogriffs not even
close to being very safe that's killed
me just killed me on top of all of that
there's the fact that a massive battle
including the death of voldemort all
takes place on hogwarts grounds scared
harry
a little
we all love watching a brilliant
quidditch match but there are some
questions when it comes to how exactly
the scoring works it seems strange that
the points jump from 10 for scoring a
goal to 150 for catching the snitch the
seeker of course requires a lot of
skills but a chaser would have to be
unbelievably talented to stand a chance
at winning if the opposing team catches
the snitch i want to take potions
there's quidditch trolls coming up i
need to practice
remember when ron told dobby where to
find bill's house it may seem like
nothing but ron wasn't the secret keeper
this is scabbers by the way
pathetic isn't he scabbers the weasley
household rat at least until he revealed
himself to be peter pettigrew there are
a few issues here why exactly did
scabbers decide to live with the
wizarding family for a full 12 years not
to mention the fact that ron held and
cared for this rat for years only to
discover he was in fact a full-grown man
with a dark and troubled past the fact
that this gets glossed over so quickly
is kinda crazy especially considering
how big a part worm tail ended up
playing in the story if we were ron we
definitely would not have been okay with
this creepy bit of information
there's also a mystery around the fact
that fred and george never noticed
pettigrew's name on the marauders map
scabbers was in ron's dorm with him all
the time so it seems like someone should
have noticed
the summoning charm is practical simple
and so often useful but the fact that it
doesn't get taught until fourth year is
suspicious especially considering how
advanced the students would be at that
point the simple spell that doesn't seem
to be on anyone's radar until the fourth
film
three
of the founders co-existed quite
harmoniously
one did not the amount of competition
between all the houses at hogwarts
doesn't seem like the healthiest
approach to building a community at the
school slytherin in particular suffers
being an unpopular house among the other
students but if they are so bad why did
no one try to change that with such a
terrible reputation it feels like
someone could have done something to
make the disliked house a little better
the in-school rivalries feel a bit too
intense
shut up malfoy
considering the dark times that we're
approaching it was weird that dumbledore
didn't prepare the students better he
may have asked snape to give harry
lessons and occlumency but he definitely
could have hired better teachers for
defense against the dark arts or at
least create a new supplementary lesson
to ensure the safety of the students
during the war do you really think
there's going to be a war series
hermione is a brilliant witch there's no
denying that however the choice that
hogwarts made to give her a time turner
so she could take more classes seems
ludicrous the girl was only 13 years old
and held an insane amount of power all
just to take some extra classes
when in doubt
i find retracing my steps to be a wise
place to begin
good luck
for those like hermione who grew up in
the muggle world and presumably went to
muggle school there seems to be very few
questions about her past life it's odd
that young hermione would just drop her
life completely and disappear sure
boarding school could be used as a cover
for hogwarts but it doesn't make sense
that hermione doesn't talk about her
life before and no one asks
serious
what are you doing here answering your
letter we've seen amazing methods of
communication from serious black
appearing in a fire to a two-way mirror
yet to send a message to someone a paper
letter is shipped via owl it's a pretty
old-school way to communicate and highly
inefficient owls are great but they can
take some time harry potter
it was against the rules for harry to
compete but in this case rules didn't
matter realistically the simple solution
would have been just to follow the rules
and not have harry compete mr potter has
no choice
after hogwarts it feels as though there
aren't many options in terms of jobs how
do they make money in the wizarding
world we know the ministry of magic st
mungo's hogwarts quidditch or a musical
career for those talented enough but
aside from these very limited options
there aren't really many careers it
feels like their economy just wouldn't
make any sense at least no one on the
gryffindor team had to buy their way in
of all the people to duel bellatrix over
the course of the movies it's a bit
perplexing that molly weasley is the one
to take her down yes her family is in
danger and bellatrix has been awful but
it does feel out of character to have
the weasley mother whip out an
unforgivable curse so quickly there are
a couple of tools used in the wizarding
world that seem quite inefficient we're
talking quills and remember alls sure
maybe the quills are for the sake of
holding up tradition but the fact that
they don't have a place for ink or
magically fill up again doesn't make
much sense for efficiency as for
rememberalls yes they may be able to
remind a person they've forgotten
something but as we saw with neville it
doesn't help to remember what one has
forgotten we love to look back on the
magic and wonderful world created in the
harry potter series even if it wasn't
the most logical place what other
details in the series didn't make sense